welcome to this video for round for the
Norway super tournament and I think it's
called the supreme masters or something
is it yes supreme masters I think I
looked it up on the website okay round
form after three rounds we have Hayekian
leading the field with three out of
three amazingly and he's followed by
Aronian and Anand both on +1 so already
one point behind and Magnus Carlsen
who's playing on home turf only is on
15% played three draws yeah okay cannot
win every game but he certainly expected
more let's look at the games I'll do it
a bit differently than in four three
rounds because I have from the two
decisive games of the I'll be spoiling a
bit are just much more interesting than
the draw so I'll do three games rather
quickly and then concentrate on the two
most interesting games we had to Palm
off playing from Luke Emma - Paulo from
on - one after losing against Arnold and
her mother has got the zero points and
the part of goes for the fianchetto line
against the green thought I'm a plain
mercy 65 and to Paolo funny enough plays
chronics innovation with e3 playing the
line of his archrival okay so we get a
relatively quiet opening maybe we can
take stock quickly here white has
developed very harmoniously good good
bishops on G 2 and a 3 and black also
hands-free and shadowed both bishops and
put
put up a solid position in the center
maybe at one point playing e5 or if the
moment is right c5 tuned to open up and
equalized in the center of course e5 is
not on at the moment Weiss has got too
much pressure on pressure on the center
but in general it looks like a position
where maybe widest very slightly better
but nothing too scary as it proceeded we
see that the situation in the center has
changed like took on c4 and opened with
E 5 and this position here I actually
have would favor white the problem is if
you look at who moves later it feels
very very normal look at this this
happened now the bishop on aged 86 has a
big problem and on d5 this is just a
very dominating piece and black has a
hard time to to defend him he probably
can but it's it's a bit uncomfortable
think he did okay first couple of moves
you need to get this piece in the play
and always watch out for these kind of
ideas rock back and now he took on d5 he
simply couldn't stand this piece any
longer this is a typical phenomenon you
don't you don't want to tolerate this
bishop any longer and simply take it but
this is in a way also concession as
white gets the very strong deep own
maybe it was better to to delay this
capture bit this is the typical kind of
situation where computers are simply
much much better than human players
simply because you you it's a matter of
nerves it's probably better not to take
so quickly but the human simply cannot
stand the tension of this this piece
and here all the time yeah and of course
white has advanced here with the h-bomb
and this world will be tricky now we see
the Dwight didn't intend to take but to
play to h6 is much stronger as it gives
the mating square on g7 at one point the
Queen might deliver mate and also you've
got the D pawn and the combined power of
both pawns of both the pawn and
decimating at least give white a really
clear advantage it's not so clear like
and defend successfully in the game yeah
I didn't analyze it so deeply it's
simply because the other games took took
too much time here look at this here in
this position the power off gave this
check
he had many many very strong options and
I think he's got winning chances in
almost all of them what he could have
done with this simple relatively simple
solution is rook III the ideas that
black of course cannot take because of
the simple mate here and what is black
supposed to do you cannot exchange here
yes now this is not avoidable
so black isn't a bit of a bit of a
bother here what what what he's supposed
to do the only play will move with King
f8 really and then Ruby 7 yeah this was
the endgame that tupelov could reach and
I think this is flat-out winning for
white it's you will get the a pawn as
well and you've got the H pawn and can
use the King this is also weakness I
think this should be a relatively
straightforward technical win this was
just one line I mean if you look at it
well
the computer that looks like it should
be super easy but White has so many
options that it is not so easy computer
also gives a 5 as winning f4 as winning
and so on but it's not so easy in fact
in the game after some moves which are
also influenced by control at the end
this exchange happened and now blacks
got counter play the a pawn is on its
way and it's not so clear how wide
should make any progresses is a pretty
solid blockade now the game after some
additional moves ended in a draw I think
for a couple of moves took off maybe
hope that he can do something on the
edge pawn and connected to this but
there's simply nothing happening like
can just go here and this is where you
protect h7 yeah I think at least them at
one point to power off could have won
the game very likely also at at other
and other points it was a narrow escape
here for the black player but as this
game this is so important for the
overall standings and the other ones are
more interesting I just showed it
briefly with this one critical point um
even less interesting unfortunately was
the game 1 however a job of we M got a
new zoo in in here and one who played f3
this is a line that I had recommended in
my repertoire serious quite a while ago
and it is a good line for white that
is possible to to be played in in many
ways some lines are very sharp but some
are also rather safe and in this case we
get a main line with this and this is
actually one of the sub variations of
this opening that has the reputation to
be very safe for white it it looks a bit
weird maybe this the statement but it
really is the case the thing is that if
you look at it what happened white has
one upon here and he's got the two
bishops what black has got and it's
favours it's got a very healthy
structure and quite often we reach this
this kind of formation you see that
black black can constantly take pawns on
c3 but she doesn't this for example
runs into a very nasty pin which is very
very from magic this for example already
already wins if black goes away with the
night this is coming like I never really
take on c3 okay on also here you can
take but it didn't really help like the
c3 pawn is not much use anyway so and
now we see them the reason why this is a
very safe line the best that black can
do is at some point um yeah sacrifice a
pawn to get his Queen side mobilize
black very often plays b6 and even even
here what was possible already black can
take here but this leads to big problems
like this
and why just has the two bishops if he
solves this one structure problem white
is of course much better yeah you see in
the game white keeps the pawn and the
best black can do really is now played
b6 and get rid of this very annoying
pawn and now you know white actually
plays this but quite often you you see
this structure where right is a bone of
and black usually has enough
compensation to get one one backward
it's it's very draw at the end if black
wins the a front one so on this is a
very safe line as mentioned in the game
right now played a5 and advanced all the
way to a6 just now after the Queen trade
we got an endgame where white is got the
two bishops but black has immediate play
against a six and yeah even certainly
should have thought about capturing but
it's not so clear that this is really a
good ideas like pieces are somewhat tied
together here you can't fly it but I
mean he didn't want to he decided to
develop first and activate pieces yeah
in fact I think after a couple of
precise moves that went on for a bit we
M reached an equal endgame like always
have chance to get a 6 back and no not
it so
didn't move forward here and here draw
was the greet because of this line yeah
and it's pretty much dead with further
exchanges coming it's possible that
there may be were improvements along the
line if if there were probably for white
as what seemed some somewhat better here
slightly better maybe only but I didn't
really invest much time to check this it
wasn't so exciting anyway and not
relevant for the world standings much
more important for the standing
Wisconsin against us Whitlow of course
Magnus needs to win this a game now as
cockiness leading with three or three so
with wide should win shall try to win
yes well as not repeating his 1e5 of the
candidates tournament but rather goes
for a mainline so slowly in a was d6 and
Carlton plays Bishop b5 check as he
usually does he rarely nowadays some
place default for the open Sicilian 97
and now a surprise are normally the most
ambitious move here is d4 and this is
what he had played early in the
tournament against Anand another
possibility is also the move c3 which
gives the bishop square on c2 for
instance something like this to allow
the retreat square the game we played
the most castles which looks an entirely
normal but the fun fact is what do you
play after a six
we should protect it needs to move you
don't really want to take and some after
deform here you get a similar position
to the one shown before but here White
has canceled already and lost lots of
this flexibility cars idea was
completely different
he played Bishop t3 which looks kinda
curious but it's not it's not bad at all
um the idea is to continue with c3 and
Bishop c2 and after all that would
deform so not a bad idea it's a bit
time-consuming but in the meantime what
what is black doing he played 86 and
tonight - and not really great scroungy
7 yeah
how should black react now I think I'm
the most normal looking Rufus 9 F 6 and
in fact the arm quite a number of games
in the database with this so Bishop d3
is not not an innovation that's been
played before amazingly I never solved
this roof but it has been played even by
the likes of Caruana so not not move you
I don't know see frequently in under 10
championships and in some some small
country or so at 7 play per grandmasters
ok but still I didn't didn't play Knight
f6 the normality movie played Knight to
e5 which in fact I'm also has been
played before but I relatively no level
game and are pretty sure that after this
game now carlins fiddler no one is going
to play Knight e5 it's it's really a
strange decision if you look at this
just a couple of normal moves f4 was to
prevent b5 you see that black has
weakened the structure here it's got a
double pole which in itself is not such
a big deal but it really clocks up the
position and gives widen and attacking
point only 5 we see that after Bishop e6
we should be - this is
hanging already and what is like
supposed to do if he plays him who fried
927 there's some this kind of setup or
so I've gotten I'd see for coming
attacking this enter if black plays a
move like g6 you always need to make
sure that f4 isn't isn't terrible and it
is really dangerous if white is coming
with their floor so it's a bit of a
tricky position swivel I decided to play
something else he took on v3 and move
you can easily overlook really because
it's so uncommon this is the setup not
theoretically uncommon but you don't see
it in other openings as well yeah the
idea is so that the bishop on the d3 is
of course hanging so if you take here
Queen takes and this is okay for black
of course but cows is simply played
Queen three two now attacking or keeping
on attacking this is upon and securing
this bishop so what blacks supposed to
do it you can retreat it's not lost or
anything but then white will get this
pawn back anyway and after that be
quicker and in the center he decided to
play c4 immediately returning upon okay
not much choice white regained the pawn
now and yeah now if we look at this a
little bit deeper we see the divide is
best better developed he's got castles
already in and an active Queen that can
drop to a safe square attacked you
should a text whoops bishop at xe5 and
black already
yeah it's somewhat behind here and
cannot easily and quickly cancel the
next moves are very very logical it's
important to note that black cannot take
on c2
after queen bee seven that's really
terrible this is also hanging and what
what is some what is black doing now
white also just threats to improve the
position further and he will win those
pawns
so what Queen c2 is not not possible at
all he seeks to get on with the good
King side ninety to ninety seven ninety
four all very logical nights before
attacking the e5 pawn and now b6 in this
position you see that b6 has secured
square a-square on c5 and it also made
sure that the white isn't playing a5 and
if you look at this a5 you can drop ones
back and ask yourself why not a 5-4
white and in fact there is no reason why
are this move should be played and this
is probably one of the critical points
in the game cotton here should have
played a five instead of not c4 it makes
sure that the support is not moving and
in fact this is a very thankless
position now the main problem is that
white would establish a knight on c4 and
this Knight is not a saleable at all
it cannot be be driven away from this
from the square of course black cannot
take it all here because of rule C 1
this is an important technical point
so we probably play and move like let's
say Bishop here and not see one similar
to the game but take note this pawn is
still on b7 and now White has got really
easy play to to improve further look b1
moving the bishop away not sure where
actually there are many ideas can go
here you can also think about the
regrouping what white is going to do is
pressure rise b7 this is just a very
nice pawn to attack in the game as
counsel played this first sweida was
quick to play b6 and prevent that and
this is really not c4 was a pretty
serious mistake that failed to yeah use
the opening advantage that that cousin
God because of spitless 19-5 move in
fact here I was I was surprised again
instead of this oops sorry
mr. top neck b6 instead of this King
edge one move
which obviously intends to go fo at some
point or advance iam I was wondering um
if white maybe should play Bishop e3 I
think probably this would have been my
choice but I understand why you don't
want to make this move it looks a bit
weird to to offer a trait against this
undeveloped Bishop but okay the idea is
to put no pressure on b6 and it it looks
like and black is holding but it's not
it's not nice I mean look at this why
just so pressing a bit I like this more
than than the game but okay it's it's an
it's understandable but Magnus tried
yeah we had a queen trade now and after
this it's witless busy to get rid of his
only possible weakness we reached a
completely completely equal position
yeah in fact there was one one
interesting possibility white could play
route 2 c1 intending to play play a rook
c8 a possible line is this yeah I'm
sorry
the bishop is saying of course this one
loop 3/8 and it seems that black is
holding it's not looking too attractive
but it doesn't seem to to to win rook
here and just just a pawn it's not clear
how white is going to improve that it
looks terribly terribly fast affected
see how wide should window and it's not
force black doesn't necessarily need to
take on these freaking also we treat the
book but roopd 3 is the most principled
move maybe this was a bit tougher in the
game um they exchanged this rook as well
and it was absolutely nothing now the
rooks come off from b8 and okay they
exchanged a couple of more yeah some
some more material and agreed to a draw
um yeah Magnus didn't exploit the chance
is in the opening given by this somewhat
strange move 95 especially curious that
he didn't play a 5 because this looks
like such a normal positional move it's
the kind of move you relatively quickly
play in a blitz game I would say because
it's just the normal thing you do and
somehow it didn't he didn't he didn't do
that and he took took us some time I
don't know how to how to tell what's the
what's the issue him when it didn't go
in five draw at the end and this is of
course not enough he really should
should have one two went to stay in the
in the hunt in this tournament
okay so we have looked at three games
now relatively quickly now look at let's
look at the two two other get other ones
two final games start with Aronian
against coyoacán yeah the situation is
kayaking three out of three and Aronian
Escott plus one so let's see what
happens Aronian certainly trying to to
go for win
yeah kayaking sticks to his guns he
placed them twins Indian basically
honest life Queen's Indian enemies of
Indian against default is very steady in
this and the bishop a six line yeah it
seems that the trendy move Queen c2 with
the pawn sacrifice ideas c55 has fallen
out of favor again and people switch
back to the old line p3 the old main
line which is really plate like I don't
know yeah thousands of times since since
the 70s there are many possible ways to
play as black one is the line that
kayaking is choosen giving the check and
dropping back this lures this bishop
into a to a bad square you much prefer
to have it on be to later and not on d2
so it's a good check note that this move
can lead to really have any problems
just to
to show a funny line the rookin strapped
or vision before it's both both good so
there are there are some some tricky
lines white really needs to play 52 yeah
now I dropped back 93 yeah this is a
much sharper move than Bishop d2 Bishop
d2 as as possible as well after that
black plays this setup he can do other
things but this is what what normally is
played Knight c3 is a bit more
aggressive the ideas that after oops
after c6 by black you can play you form
immediately and then play a position
like that or Bishop d3 this is also also
possible looks a bit funny with g3 to
ignore this later and go there should be
three but it's a it's a line okay a
kayaking cathode first Bishop d2 and now
c6 NT 5 and we get we follow for a while
the game um Hama against kayaking it's
very it was very very similar I don't
want to get so much into the details
here of the opening face it's much more
interesting later in general I must say
that I'm absolutely not impressed what
white is doing in this in this in this
game somehow it feels that the light on
on sheath and a4 and the weakened Queen
side are problem look at this what is
this a four-night doing it cannot easily
drop back or here because of 93 I'm not
so sure it's probably about about equal
this position but I really am
don't don't see the big point of white
setup it obviously was a piece of
preparation both players were playing
very quickly
whereas this a function of the clock no
I mean the clock here on ICC what they
record but they played it instantly up
to now in our kayak and spend some time
20 minutes almost on Luke C&C 8 so on
the questions for me what is what is
White's big plan in fact it very quickly
a god critical rook c8
well answered by Bishop h3 and this was
obviously the idea that Aronian had this
group supposed to go doesn't really have
the good square so you play a fire and
support d4 Knight also if 396 and 23
yeah funny enough now Aronian is taking
lots of time for this f3 move yesterday
this is the kind of preparation that I
don't understand it's not like I'm doing
heavy criticism here just hard for me to
figure how you play all this instantly
now then the opponent plays the normal
most normal moves ever rook c8 after
Bishop h3 yield yeah you pretty much
fourth and five and then you spend like
40 minutes to play a3 is really curious
so it's funny sometimes
okay a drop back to d6 of course to d6
because here here's a potentially good
square 1 d6 that covers also f5 so nice
one Queen d3 attacking one f5
yeah blacking out took and here it's a
very very critical point in this game
um I think in this position here white
also it's not the most principled move
of course but here white also could have
taken with the bishop and kept the pawn
structure completely symmetrical this is
of course not exactly the kind of move
you play if you if you want to win the
game which Aronian certainly what the
Roman certainly intended to do being one
point behind his direct rival but this
looks much safer to me he took with the
porn okay and now after the exchange
black went 94 here also Roxy what was
the possibility instead of Bishop c1 we
can we can have a look at that yeah of
course after Luke c1 black also plays
Knight c4 did not intend to go backwards
and now let's say it's quite sharp what
about this f5 pawn is the just hanging
yeah white can take it and now it's
really funny because black has got yeah
a whole host of options it's really
really curious
for example the weird-looking poof rook
takes the f5 is even even interesting
look at this after g5 you have the
bishop trapped quite I think out of the
blue the bishop is trapped and it's a
total mess white can take on g5 for
example and play even f4 yeah I have no
idea what's going on here it's one
possibility
black can can 2nd f5 but he doesn't need
to
he has other ideas you can also play the
move Bishop g5 it's rather strong if
white takes here
for example and does this there's this
rope hanging this is a very important
point an effect with
complete position blackest winning
results of bet note that in all those
lines
why does playing a piece down the a fall
night he somehow never managed to to get
this night back into play so this is
some if white takes some with the rook
he took with the Bishop which is
understandable because as you solve this
Bishop can get in trouble so it took
with that and not c4 and it get a very
very complicated position what should we
do if we look at this Bishop f5 there's
Knight e5 this is already good for black
if you look at yeah white can take it if
you want takes and now drop back for
example there's simply this move and
also d4 as an additional way to increase
the pressure white is playing a piece
down that's it's it's really curious in
some very often complicated positions
and and complicated metals on the
chessboard can be stripped down to to
one single essence one point and here it
is this is offside knight on e4 somehow
there's lots of action in the center and
the knight is not really participating
what is white supposed to do with Bishop
f5 is not the solution we saw that I
think what he should have done probably
it's not nice but this is probably rook
e1 protecting the pawn with the with the
route in the game he played f4 which is
um yeah understandable but look at this
it opens up this long diagonal and
weakens the structure and we see that
the liability the knight is again the
problem it's it's a check now retreats
and now clean v6 check with the tempo
rook F 2 and d 4 this is forced after F
4 and this is also why I think that why
it should have avoided that look at this
now the knight is again kicked and
they're funny enough it could have gone
to a 4 because of this Nazi whining and
it's not great but just to show it one
line is this with a fantastic position
for blank look at those centralized
pieces and white only has got bad bad
pieces the bishop is not doing much this
Bishop is not doing much and black has
got an accent horn at the centre yeah
this was 94 you don't want to do that
again on the rim he played Knight to e2
which is probably better in comparison
but white is already in big big trouble
here maybe it is already impossible to
save the game it was really funny as I'm
not I'm not so sure
it really is f4 the decisive mistake it
really needs to - big trouble but it's
it's it's so hard to believe I mean the
whole setup is probably a bit risky with
us as mentioned offside night and look
like f4 maybe really puts it puts it
over the edge okay
92 and now loop d8 again very strong
cockiness playing simple but very strong
chassis ER he abandons the F pawn
simply because the D pollicis is much
too strong if white takes here now
that's Queen c6
and curtains what can resign no way to
prevent Queen h1 and and wins yeah what
can can do this too
to shield from the readmit but blacks
got this one so quite a funny quite a
funny mate
so Bishop f5 wasn't playable at all
he went for Queen takes at five but now
we see the blockade is lifted on the on
the d3 square and like playing to d3
yeah why was that urge to take the pawn
black was threatening we should be from
deadly you you really don't have a move
here if you play it something like this
that's for instance there's again this
and this is just rocket on the pond it
just flies all the way home to d1y okay
so in the game Queen a 553 yeah a check
and now the D pawn it's it's unstoppable
Aronian give gave this this piece and
now I'm last try with a6 was refuted by
the simple capture getting rid of the
porn yeah I'm not quite sure when you
resigned here yeah wrong and resigned in
view of Queen age one mate yeah this
means kayaking is on 4 or 4 and after
the game he said the last time he had
four wins in the tournament that the
start must have been at some under 10
championship probably this is correct
often this is said in jest and today's
one tournament where he did this did
this qualified to start but for him
category I don't know what is 21 or
something a super indie tournament
starting with four wins is really
unheard of
so yeah out-of-this-world start for
kayaking place obviously very precisely
and punished
Aronian some maybe slightly loose plane
it's it's really hard to assess this I
mean I don't really like it I have a
ever complete a version against their
putting stuff on the on the rim I'm
honest there even if it is good I don't
like to do it and therefore are maybe a
bit biased against whites play assembly
I hated to have a knight on e4 which
doesn't do anything and maybe this race
raised the stakes so high that um
further mistake with f4 was really
leading to a position that you cannot
repair anymore okay so this one game
left open
this is our ninth against Nakamura yeah
are not on plus one so it's got this
position on place to in the in the
standing right behind kayaking one one
point down and he just want a nice game
against Apollo while my camera on see
150 percent I think he's on -1 right
I would have needed to needed to look it
up I think he's on -1 if I'm not
mistaken and yeah so certainly an answer
tries to depress him played before and
to the camera in place a lots of
openings he played he 5 and we got a
rule no pass in fact we got this sort of
improved I'm sorry improved um um arch
angel variation proudest today this is a
very curious line because it doesn't
really have a yeah a completely an
established name it's one of the most
popular lines in the Rue La Paz and
that say 15 years but it's not quite
sure how it is should be called some
people call it the Ducati of variation
because the russian-ukrainian vladislav
scott Jeffords originally from Russia or
Ukraine
hopefully not wrong here and but he's
living in France for a long time now he
is some very young he has been one of
the main persons to put this into the
limelight but also fear of has played it
very very often he also published I
think even more than one DVD on it and I
mantis has played this Linus black many
times so it's a very popular line that
doesn't really have a well-established
name another name is this cut of this
name neo Arkhangelsk there's the art
angles variation with blue should be
seven or arch angel
strangely enough Lloyd is sometimes in
English called
Bishop c5 is sort of improved version of
Bishop d7 simply because sometimes the
bishop can be used on this diagonal okay
so long introduction to this opening
it's all very normal
note that here it's a important trick
important trick that black shouldn't
take on uniform because it should be
five texts both nights
it's a funny motif I cannot take but it
can just cancel 92 rookie AIDS all very
normal
rookie 195 and c5 so black managed to
get in this typical performance c5 that
often is delayed in the window peasant
it needs some preparation to play it
like 95 or move the knight c6 to some
other square 25 I'm not an expert on on
this line for black eye
play e5 for years now but I always
played the classical lines with Bishop
to e7 so I cannot really tell the
theoretical status offer for this the
only thing that I can I can say judging
from my experience and in you know
passable games I think it's quite for me
at least surprising that an ant went for
this because frankly speaking looks like
nothing if this is all that white can do
against Bishop c5 then maybe I should
actually pick it up because we are what
what exactly is why it's plain here like
it can even play c4 later I get to get
this exchanged and he's not even he
doesn't even have a space disadvantage
or anything it just looks like black has
some effortlessly : equal position yeah
Knight g4 interesting way to play right
everyone and we should be six note that
the exchange is not especially good
because this helps white to maybe get a
knight on d5 first this move this
introduces this possibility amongst
others Knight g5 yeah the technical way
or or concrete let's say way to to
tackle this this position it leads to
some exchanges 93 96 now interesting um
the camera checked with the porn this is
a very good decision at first you think
okay why why exactly was Rookie three
rookie six um was there some some
tactical problem no but if you look at
this position White has ideas with the
night he can especially to define if
Knight f5 isn't such a big deal because
you probably can't like g6 and kick it
out but look at the knight on d5 this is
not easy
all to get rid of and it really gives
yeah it somehow injects some sense into
whites position if you are able to play
Knight to d5 here white is probably
better but the camera plate f takes is
very good and not it's not terribly
difficult for for a good player but it's
very important to note that the double
points are not so so much of a problem
but it's much more important that the
six point covers d5 and f5
Knight takes one else and c4 yes so this
was what Hamas was aiming for with this
Knight g5 operation and I think that
this position is route equal it's
nothing special for for for I love right
side I I think black has got this double
bond which nicely controlled central
squares but it also is a slight
liability it can be attacked at a later
stage a problem for white though is that
this Bishop is not doing much it just
protects the pawn and it's not doing
anything else this is a strong piece and
the knight on e5 yeah it can be improved
with 96 of course on Knight d7 to c5
might might be an idea as well so I
think it's about equal let's see what
happens Queen age 5 Queen to c7 or
normal at covering the pawn Knight g4
attacking it and now strong move rook f8
using counter play against f2 so white
cannot capture on d5 because this this
wins the house
rookie to covering the weakness and now
work to dat interesting news what what
happens now if white takes on 25 we
should have a brief look at this it's
very strong attacking f2 and pinning the
knight on the fifth rank this is
actually already winning for black
simply no move there's this threat and
this will pick up the night so there are
many little tactical ideas here Queenie
five can be answered with this and black
has quite good good chances here can
always get this back and have the active
position it at least doesn't help in any
way for white if you want to try for
something yeah lock plate plate just
rook t1 then exchanged the rook rook to
e8 taking the bishop
we hope c2 so now a critical moment of
the game in fact all upcoming moves now
are critical because it gets really
sharp now quickly this position now if
you look at it at first it looks some
not too spectacular still up maybe about
about even but there are some features
in the position that that make it a
little bit a little bit tricky and one
key feature is the weak back rank that
white has and in fact
so black this bishop is the only piece
that covers the back rank this is
something you always need to be aware of
and this is also why rookie - it was
necessary to do this move but it's a bit
of a shaky move because just a heavy
piece only one and your mate
you made it um yeah what is black
supposed to do now I think the the
normal move would be maybe knight c6 you
get this Knight back and try to use it
in the center like I'm gonna plate
something out though he was playing very
quickly
he played before now after some thought
and I think this is in fact a very very
serious mistake which um you can of
course this is it's always the same
which you can easily find out if you
check it with an engine but it's not the
kind of admits and reputation that I
think are not really should see I'm not
really sure why why he didn't go for
that because it's it's pretty evident
that at least in my mind that this is a
good move he measured probably are not
able to calculate all of it but I think
you pretty quickly recognize that this
is the one you you should play um first
we should look again quickly at Knight
takes d5 this is now not working because
of b3 yeah
as mentioned the back ranked white can
can go here but after g6 Queen moves 96
this is actually lost the problem being
96 rook t3 and there's maid threatens
and the knight s is gone
it's it's over so this is this is not
the move not 1935 but White has a very
strong tactical idea and this is rook to
d2
using the fact that blacks black has got
a weak back rank as well and once you
see the moves I cannot believe that Hana
didn't see it at all once you see the
move I think it's pretty pretty clear
that it should be a good move you take
the D file and instantly get rid of the
mating ideas Rock d1 where you again you
get made it and yeah you can calculate
some lines and and they're all excellent
for what I think white has a substantial
advantage after root t2 for example it's
all it's still tricky if black plays
nothing looks let's say this - it's not
a comedian nothing movement I move that
doesn't change so much one can even
simply take all this Queen d2 at the end
can be M can be answered by taking and
the simple move like a ch3 and why this
white is better after this just at just
one line h6 is not a problem not a
particularly useful move and then the
important point is if black drops back
here improving the night covering the
spawn there's the good move Bishop a4
and suddenly this Bishop is is alive and
is doing a good job but the idea to take
and at the end take e5
frankly speaking there is no good news
no for black what what else is there if
you play em let's say you go back to f8
just for argument's sake then white can
simply take it if I were saying there is
no compensation so it's really curious
that Ana didn't see this after strange
time that is the time given it is very
weird what he did is he took on before
and this is a mistake it's not leading
to big trouble already for white but the
other move was simply giving what a
pretty big age 96 back this was
Nakamura's idea he attacks now d4 and 94
he was playing aggressively and very
often it's the case that aggressive play
that is probably not 100% correct
history wallet because grabbing the
initiative is always uncomfortable for
the opponent yeah it seems that in this
position again
Anand should play rook d2 it seems to
like the best move anyway
however Knight d4 is of course now a
completely different animal instead of
having it on a5 like it's not one
default but you can you can go here and
protect protect your your position and
this seems seems alright note that black
cannot play something like this it's
again a medium and this was probably the
best after Bishop a4 now but on one
plate
there was night eggs before super move
and it was played and now it gets gets
rather tricky and the reason is again 93
supporting and improving increasing the
pressure on f2
there's still the mating ideas let's
have a look
25 this is what Allen played he grabbed
grab the ball and Queenie 7 yeah we can
look at this position this was some
really very tricky to to play maybe a
wide shot think about going going back
here maybe it was a tough for defense
but it's it's very very tricky already
just just the sample line 93 Queen takes
Knight f4 how do you defend this it's a
it's really tricky now let's say let's
say look back Queen g5 mightier and this
major on g2 so he cannot play Knight
back even black has a very strong
initiative and the game Allen to decided
to go on Queen to h5
yeah no Nakamura had a choice a very
important choice he has to Knight moves
can go to b3 I can capture the pawn the
93 was a good move let's just have a
look it looks very natural not to take
and to taken rather unimportant pawn at
the moment but to increase the pressure
probably g3 because Knight f4 was wasn't
threat and now and I'm not sure there
are many many interesting moves rook f8
or Bishop to d4 can be a good move
centralizing there's always the B to
pawn that can be won a black hat black
has excellent playing m4 for the pawn
it's hard to tell what was better he
took on a tomb which I think
according also and supported by the
engine gave white a chance to get out of
this this trouble white obviously is in
some trouble after his misses with
Bishop a4 and not playing root D - yeah
white it seems can't play Knight to e5
but this is a very very complicated line
and it's not not easy at all - to
calculate a possibility just just to
show why this is so tricky if black goes
night to see one taking the rook you
need to go rook to c2 it's already very
shaky yeah no look look at this rookie
193 and and this is this is over it's
too much the pawn f2 white white will
collapse you need to go to this very
weird square c2 which looks completely
insane and this is why I'm saying this
is very much a computerized line because
now you're only defending d1 the mate
square root d1 mate with the Queen the
you just blocked the bishop from a phone
it's just the technical thing g6 24 and
Queen d6 and now this may be the moment
where you stop to calculate and think oh
my gosh how am I going to going to
defend this now you maybe see whoopsy 1
and queen e5 and this is the threat this
is no threat it's it's really tricky and
it's not even a pawn I mean black has
gotten the phone back like it's a big
pressure
in fact the the move that saves right
here's the amazing Bishop to d7 which is
completely crazy no one is going to to
calculate this 95 rooks into the soul
sequences is completely nuts but it is a
drop now I can can show you this is even
losses because this one hanging this one
hanging is it's just an extra exchange
so what's like supposed to do you can't
take here and after this funny enough
it's it's all working out nicely
oops sorry
of course with the hoops
rook t2 and of course with the bishop
took the one took the wrong on a PCM
with the bishop and then it's it's it
already and no one can calculate this I
mean I am pretty sure that Anand did
consider ninety-five centralizing is
always move oops
I move to consider it's also introducing
this possibility but it is very
difficult to play all this another line
Queen d6 you go g3 yeah and now g6 it
sounds slightly different here white can
actually oh sorry I can take you can
take him yeah I have some notes prepared
and it's it's a bit of a jungle of of
lines here we can you can actually take
here and this is still I'm still okay
for white but it's a few of your
tactical things that you can easily
screw up while calculating
in the game are not didn't play 95 this
was probably either way to go and maybe
this is why 9 takes a to was at least
theoretically worse than 93 but from a
practical point of united to basically
won the game won because now on unplayed
g3 and this this basically gives it away
because black has a very strong move now
this is 91 played by nakamura simply
attacking the rook and where it is
supposed to go it went to see to the
rook and the absolute relative would be
to yeah to drop back but this after 93
is also not nice at all just look at
this so lots of lots of pressure and
there are additional problems let's say
here there's Queen B for attacking the
offside Bishop introducing this idea
itself it's quite quite a problem this
is another important important point the
black can improved to to d4 even and
here white will probably collapse quite
quickly the relatively best defense is
Bishop c2 know but we're getting really
deepened into the lines now here it is
funny that this isn't even the best move
here this is clearly better for black
but the game continues black can even
decide not to take and play improving
moves like Bishop c5 and so on white
really has no move the problem is that
the queen is it's not doing much to have
no squares you can try Queen g5 but
maybe then I'll take that sounds even
somewhat better in comparison
yeah why does why does in petroleum I
think he he cannot defend this in the
game it led to see me on the plane
he went oops he went to see 293 and now
e5 but instead of E 5 you can look at
other moves of you for example player
rookie 2 again
then there's a Gannon rook f8 Queen
before it's a transposition if I from
has got the idea I believe to play
Bishop c6 in fact one thing that that I
should say I really doubt the clock
times I'm only now looking at them and I
cannot really believe that both had 35
minutes on the clock this really would
be a quite weird time management and in
such a complicated position before okay
II five the idea I think is Bishop c6 we
should be for if possible the the
drawback is the Queen has got even less
squares now rook evade and now
woopsie from and if white tries to
realize this plan now with Bishop Percy
six there's a strong reply in repair
five the Queen it's a it's a problem if
white now plays Queen e8 for instance
there's this and very sad night and
resigns I cannot go
Queenie eight but yeah where do you go
at some it's really ugly now something
like this
and it explodes everything's hanging
after to e5 it's it's it's just terrible
our there's also this one yeah far too
much so this is just bus that you cannot
go Bishop c6 he decided to to take on c4
but this didn't really help the camera
just took on f2 took on f2 and king g2
was played
if white decides to capture there's the
very strong move Queen a7 this is even
stronger than the simple recapture
because now it's it's a made threat and
possibly look f2 in case of Kings
here it's just over drops back there's
this one and it's completely completely
winning one problem is that this check
is met with a counter check don't have
that too often but check round set by
check is always nice so you play the
King G 2 so far more obvious and now
Bishop c5 back this is strong it allows
this kind of check and also introduces
this idea quite nice play to Bishop to
c6 if white plays nothing means yeah I'm
not sure what nothing moves there is
let's let's do this
just fall you in second then this is the
idea
[Music]
and the very cute made you king before
is a nonsense move it was just to show
the the threat basically all right white
has no no safe anymore
played Bishop d6 and now we will get
five strong just attacking here and
white now went mad to it Queen to h4 on
this move like an exchange like King
arranged this is very nice if the bishop
now retreats that's ninety one with the
mate very nice mates everything's
working nicely together and this is of
course also made so Queen e8 wasn't
exactly winning it wasn't exactly
helping winning it's also not winning of
course yeah I played the Queen and Queen
to h4 and now Knight you want check King
to H 3 and the super move Queen to f7
and this is the the last stroke here
rook h5 coming and there is no way to
prove to prevent it at first I thought
oh wait what about this one but then
this Bishop e7 with the Queen is trapped
it's really tragic tragic position it's
also not not saving so we played rook
takes and gave up the Queen but after
this additional moves are not reside so
on this is this is threatened this is
strategy will lose even more material
it's not just Queen against rook and the
bishop you lose monitor computers on -12
so some very very very qiyam
so very nice
and strong win man Nakamura aren't only
had one one point in the game where he
could have played much better with
rookie to quickly go back to this point
before really was an aggressive but
probably that move because of this but I
don't missed it and after that got into
substantial problems which she couldn't
solve over the god and it was difficult
would have been difficult even was much
more time and so but with them at the
time it was hard to defend and at the
end he he went down so what does this
mean before for the standing yeah
kayaking has got four points now Aronian
lost against kayaking
and Arnold lost against Nakamura
so kayaking misleading with fear four
out of four
and his two points ahead if I'm not
mistaken it's really funny everything
else everybody else got fifty percent or
less so it's really really funny I think
the only conceivable way is that that
maybe Carlton is beating kayaking head
and wins one more ton of more games but
otherwise kayaking really has it in the
bag probably has unless he is really
starting to loosen are lots of games
yeah I hope you enjoyed the video I
think it was was an interesting
interesting game especially at the end
here by anima camera thanks for watching
and I'll be back tomorrow with the next
robot round five